digamos que tengo una función multi
variable vamos a llamarle efe y esta
función depende de dos entradas vamos a
suponer dos entradas x xii y no sé vamos
a inventarnos alguna digamos que esto es
x cuadrada y más el seno de y más el
seno de ella entonces como podemos ver
esta es una función que toma valores
escalares aunque tiene dos entradas
verdad entonces la pregunta que vamos a
hacernos en este vídeo es cómo podemos
tomar la derivada de una expresión de
este estilo y hay un método que es el
método de las derivadas parciales y es
muy parecido a digamos cuando tomamos
derivadas tradicionales verdad así que
veremos de hecho que son casi lo mismo
así que vamos vamos a recordar un poco
cómo es la notación de las derivadas
tradicionales tenemos digamos tomemos
una función f x una función tradicional
y digamos que ésta es x cuadrada
entonces tenemos x cuadrada y la
notación que a mí más me gusta es esta
que es la notación de lights vamos a
poner de efe el sobre de x y pensemos en
un punto digamos en 2 verdad a mí me
gusta mucho la anotación de límites
porque al menos sugiere que es lo que
está ocurriendo verdad geométricamente
entonces yo no gráfica digamos ponemos
aquí un eje vamos a hacerlo derechito
ponemos un eje y ponemos otro eje aquí
está xy aquí vamos a poner fx verdad
entonces esto se ve más o menos como una
parábola cierto entonces si nosotros nos
paramos en x igualados digamos aquí está
el 2 y pensamos en este punto verdad
entonces la la noción o lo que nos dice
la anotación de límites tomémonos un
pequeño incremento en la variable que
sigamos piensen en un empujoncito de la
variable x y esto sería nuestro de x y
ahora pensamos cómo sería el cambio
en nuestra función efe al movernos
digamos con este empujoncito de x así
que todo esto será el cambio en verdad
entonces esto sería el cambio en f
verdad entonces en realidad estamos
pensando cómo cambia la salida de
nuestra función al hacer un pequeño
cambio en nuestra entrada muy bien
entonces aquí por supuesto estamos en x
igual a 2 y en realidad aquí lo que
estamos haciendo es pensar en el
cociente verdad es decir estamos
pensando en la pendiente verdad la
pendiente y esto depende por supuesto
del punto en donde estemos pero también
podríamos pensar esta misma idea sin
gráficas digamos consideremos aquí una
recta aquí tenemos nuestro espacio de
entradas equis y pongamos aquí en
nuestro espacio de salida
efe si nosotros nos digamos colocamos en
un punto aquí verdad y hacemos un ligero
cambio en x
pero cambio en x le estamos dando un
empujoncito de nuestro punto inicial
entonces la forma en la que
interpretamos a nuestra función f es que
de alguna forma estamos mapeando esta
recta a nuestro espacio de salidas
verdad entonces uno podría preguntarse
cómo afecta a la salida al haber hecho
un pequeño cambio en x así que si
digamos que nuestro punto bajo la
función que hay aquí entonces podríamos
pensar que nuestro cambio en la función
que vamos a denotar como de f pues a lo
mejor fue muy grande verdad un pequeño
cambio en x nos dio este cambio en f y
estoy mencionando todo esto porque el
cálculo de varias variables hacemos
exactamente lo mismo entonces nosotros
podríamos pensar en digamos un cambio de
nuestra función
efe digamos al variar la variable x
entonces pensemos cómo cambia nuestra
función f al variar x verdad y digamos
pensémoslo en un punto particular en el
punto 1
2 muy bien entonces vamos a ver la
influencia del cambio en x en nuestra
salida verdad entonces vamos a pensar
nuevamente en cambios de x y ver cómo
afecta en la salida de nuestra función
entonces aquí pensamos otra vez en
nuestro espacio de entradas pensemos en
nuestro espacio de entradas que
técnicamente es un plano verdad aquí
está x aquí estará de verdad y nos
colocamos en el punto 1,2 aquí estará el
2 muy bien aquí estará nuestro punto 1 2
y ahora si pensamos en un incremento
pequeño de x podríamos pensar en este
pequeño empujoncito en la dirección x
verdad y vemos cómo afecta en nuestro
espacio de salidas entonces a lo mejor
aquí está nuestro espacio de salidas
verdad aquí estará efe y a lo mejor si
ese punto cae a este otro de acá vemos
que nuestro camión efe en estar digamos
en esta en este ejemplo a lo mejor va en
dirección contraria verdad aquí puede
estar el cambio en abajo nuestro cambio
en f pero podríamos hacer este mismo
argumento al cambiar la variable y
entonces podríamos pensar en cómo cambia
nuestra función o cómo se ve afectada al
variar ligeramente y lo podríamos pensar
en el mismo punto verdad entonces en
este caso estaríamos cambiando digamos
estaríamos moviéndonos un poquito en la
dirección de y aquí estaríamos haciendo
un pequeño empujoncito en la dirección
de iu y vemos cómo afecta
a las salidas entonces quizás al mover
ye podríamos tener un efecto contrario
podría ser que sea un cambio muy grande
y del otro lado verdad hacia el hacia la
otra dirección aquí podríamos tener cómo
afecta a nuestra salida entonces todo
esta es la idea digamos de las derivadas
parciales pero aquí estamos haciendo un
mal uso de la notación en realidad
tenemos que usar una nueva anotación
para distinguir las funciones que tienen
varias variables entonces en vez de
utilizar esta de vamos a utilizar una de
que es digamos como curvada vamos a
quitar estas veces que es una anotación
solo para las funciones de una variable
cuando tenemos varias variables cuando
tenemos varias variables usamos una d
que es como curva dita verdad entonces
esta de curveada se lee como parcial
literalmente entonces sería aquí parcial
de f con respecto a la variable x o
parcial de f con respecto a la variable
de verdad y se le llama parcial pues no
nos dice toda la historia de cómo está
cambiando nuestra
en realidad solo nos dice cómo cambia al
movernos en cierta dirección ya sea en
la dirección de x o en la dirección de
verdad entonces aquí por ejemplo solo
nos dice cómo cambia la función en la
dirección así que en realidad cada una
sólo nos da una pequeña parte de la
historia de nuestra función así que
ahora sí vamos a calcular estás
derivadas así que vamos a darnos un
espacio por acá aquí tenemos todo esto
todo esto muy bien para poder calcular
estas derivadas parciales así que vamos
a calcular la derivada parcial de
nuestra función con respecto a la
variable x y digamos vamos a hacerlo en
el punto 1,2 muy bien entonces
recordemos sólo nos vamos a mover en la
dirección de x así que si sólo nos
movemos en la dirección de x en realidad
vamos a considerar hay como una
constante es decir en este caso y va a
valer 2 muy bien entonces esto lo
podremos reescribir como la derivada
parcial con respecto de x de la
expresión que tenemos aquí pero aquí
lleva a ser igual a 2 entonces tenemos x
cuadrada x 2
el seno de 2
seno de 2 muy bien esta es la derivada
parcial con respecto de x y esta
expresión ya es ya sólo depende de x
entonces podemos tomar una derivada
tradicional verdad entonces aquí la
derivada de x cuadrada sería 2x
multiplicada por una constante sería 4x
verdad pues esta constante es 2
as la derivada del seno de 2 pero esto
es una constante entonces esto
simplemente vale 0 y en todo esto
tenemos que recordar siempre que vamos a
evaluar en x igual a 1 verdad que es el
punto en donde estamos parados verdad
aquí será tomando x igual a 1 y si
tomamos x igual a 1 esto simplemente nos
da 4 verdad vamos a ver qué ocurriría
con nuestra derivada parcial con
respecto de ye en la derivada parcial
con respecto de ye en el punto 12 ahora
consideraremos a la variable x como
constante verdad no nos va a interesar
en realidad sólo la vamos a tomar como 1
así que esto será la derivada parcial
con respecto de y de la expresión que ya
teníamos pero tomando x igual a 1 verdad
entonces será 1 al cuadrado 1 al
cuadrado que multiplica y más el seno de
iu
es el seno de iu y todo esto lo vamos a
evaluar en g
igual a 2 verdad vamos a ponerle un
poquito más a la izquierda en igualados
entonces otra vez esto se vuelve una
derivada tradicional verdad aquí tenemos
que derivar ya que nos da uno por uno al
cuadrado es uno más la derivada del seno
de ye que es co seno de ye y todo esto
lo tenemos que evaluar en que igualados
y si evaluamos tendremos uno más el
coseno de dos muy bien uno más el coseno
de dos entonces ésta es una derivada
parcial digamos en un punto verdad en el
punto 1,2 pero a nosotros nos gustaría
una fórmula general que sea útil en
cualquier punto verdad así que vamos a
hacer algo muy similar pero en lugar de
poner una constante sólo vamos a
considerar a x 'guaje' constante según
sea el caso es entonces vamos a
todo esto
todo esto y no vamos a pensar en el 12
vamos a pensar en un punto punto
arbitrario equis y así que vamos a
pensar en el punto x coma y vamos a
pensar en el punto x coma y muy bien
entonces recordemos en este caso vamos a
considerar a la variable y como una
constante entonces vamos a derivar con
respecto de x nuestra expresión x
cuadrada y voy a poner con otro color
allí para que quede claro que eso va a
ser constante más
y el seno de iu
se nos dé muy bien
entonces sigue es constante verdad vamos
a pretender que esto es constante
entonces al derivar este sumando
tendremos la derivada de una constante
por equis cuadrada será 2x 2x por
nuestra constante
más más la derivada con respecto de x
del seno de pero como esto es una
constante para fines de derivar con
respecto de x entonces esto nos da 0
verdad y entonces esta formulita 2x es
la fórmula general para la derivada
parcial de f con respecto a x en un
punto arbitrario xy por ejemplo si
ponemos 12 tendríamos 2 x 1 x 2 que es 4
que era lo que teníamos anteriormente
vámonos ahora con la derivada parcial
con respecto de y entonces nuevamente
vamos a considerar ahora a x como una
constante verdad vamos a derivar esta
misma expresión x cuadrada x
más él
seno de iu
más el seno de iu y esto lo vamos a
derivar con respecto a que entonces en
este caso x cuadrada es una constante
verdad y sólo derivamos y la derivada de
y es uno y esto nos queda x cuadrada y
derivamos seno de ye que es co seno de
iu entonces otra vez esta es nuestra
fórmula general para la derivada parcial
de f con respecto a y en un punto
cualquiera verdad si ponemos 12
tendríamos 1 + coseno de 2 que era lo
que teníamos han tenido anteriormente
entonces en resumen todo esto es la idea
de una derivada parcial simplemente
vamos a pretender que una de las
variables es constante y vamos a tomar
derivadas ordinarias y sólo tenemos que
recordar que esto es así pues sólo nos
estamos moviendo en una dirección de la
entrada y vemos cómo es que esto influye
a la salida verdad en el próximo vídeo
te mostraré lo que significa esto en
términos de pendientes y gráficas pero
siempre es bueno comprender que no solo
se pueden estudiar digamos las derivadas
en término
gráficas y pendientes y es que por
ejemplo si si hablamos de funciones
vectoriales o con tres entradas ya no
podemos ver la gráfica pero la idea de
empujar poco y ver cómo cambia la
función es más general y ayudará para
continuar en el estudio del cálculo de
varias variables